so when the clans are here you just tell
them this is available yeah in any
number I'm any print in African print
Sylvia Oh War II is a designer and an
entrepreneur her new collection is a
mixture of sporty American with African
colors Africa is trendy and sells well
on the international market Uganda's
best-known designer produces above all
for her country's growing middle class
they ease a lot of opportunity for the
youth to be able to come unbecoming
middle class because they're hungry
they're like cheetahs they're fast they
want you know that they're on Instagram
or Facebook they're they want to be a
part of the rest of the world they have
internet access and are well educated
and young two-thirds of Ugandan ZAR
under 24 they are moving from rural to
urban areas and launching new firms the
government says one in three Ugandan 's
now belongs to the middle class but
other sources say 10% silvia owari says
it's a very small group between the few
extremely rich and the poor the jobless
rate is 60 percent one of the highest in
Africa this clothing market has a
limited supply only used clothing from
Europe and the US we have the best in
the world second to Egypt so we are not
using the resources that you basically
have good textiles be the future
industry of Eastern Africa it's still
tiny compared to Asia sub-saharan Africa
accounts for less than 1% of global
clothing production corruption is
another problem including in Uganda
which weighs on many companies Sylvia Oh
War II processes materials from domestic
weeding mills she's trained 200 women to
be seamstresses and is currently filling
a contract from Los Angeles for us at
the moment it's not just necessarily how
much or how big the order is is us be
being out there to be for us to be
exposed and start to be in stores all
over the world that's what's important
entrepreneurship instead of development
aid small and medium-sized enterprises
say that along with foreign investment
will help sustain Uganda's growth